talkers joey d is here your host co-host
with my main man the flying jew and
in-house tonight is my brother from a
different mother philadelphia's own
steve simone and [ __ ]
[ __ ] hooking us up on easter making
[ __ ] meatballs and stuff oh my god
beautiful thank you i tried my best that
was it was good to have family there
yeah you always make it seem like a
family that's very nice you're one of
the few people that uh
really goes out of the way [ __ ]
tremendous desserts oh my god you had
baked ziti which i think you made for me
because i have been talking about i did
a lasagna and then i was like
talking about fake ziti
[ __ ]
we should do that this sunday what's
that magazine
yeah
because i'm finally in town for a little
bit we'll do it let's do it sunday
sunday i'm in town too let's do it up
lisa yeah what do you think how was your
weekend little lee i had a good weekend
what'd you do just kind of hung out paul
had her first week at work and she's a
little under the weather so we just hung
out we worked out
just had some good food
started watching the sopranos and we
just started watching the wire so we had
a i had a good [ __ ] weekend double
festival you didn't get no sun
that little sun tan you got last week
[ __ ] lasted three days
away immediately and canoe you know
saying
santa barbara and jumped into that i
like kayaking but that scares paula
does she so what the [ __ ] just put in a
kayak with a helmet like nobody else
does it they do they put everything on
those people she's not worried about her
head she's worrying about drowning [ __ ]
it
what did you guys do last week did you
go in the ocean yeah we did those little
water bikes
in the water yeah okay yeah but it's
impossible to fall if you fall off you
deserve to fall off if you [ __ ] fall
off you deserve to die anyway hopefully
a shark will [ __ ] bite you riding a
bicycle in the water what's wrong with
you
it was fun though i know it's fun
how was your weekend very good denver
was uh
it was weird because it hit me hard
thursday what had happened it's like uh
listen this is an expression that uh
uh
at the wake at meadows priano's wake the
mother
somebody said olivia soprano if she fell
in the sewer she come out with two
[ __ ] gold watches
you know she's one of those people
i got to tell you something i went
through some bad times in my life
but i always came out
on top i don't know how i did it oh it's
not a insult it's not like an insult no
no when i went to prison i could have
been so worse and it came on it was
everything it was everything in my favor
every you know i didn't get exactly what
i wanted but at least i got out of there
it could have been worse could have been
nine [ __ ] years absolutely yeah uh
this situation listen when i left
boulder in june what happened was in uh
in in 95 i was going through this war
with my ex-wife and and i went to
michigan to do a weekend memorial day
and i met this crazy stripper the one
that pulled the aluminum foil out of the
[ __ ]
and she came to colorado and she goes
i'm moving to seattle she spent the week
with me in boulder with her brother
and then she went to seattle and she
said i'm gonna get an apartment first
come on up and stay with me so i had
that option the comedy works had banned
me
and i had nothing going on with the wife
or whatever i was basically broke i mean
i basically had maybe
300 bucks and triple called me and gave
me a bunch of work that led me to
seattle wow it was like a godsend like
last night was in like look la range or
oregon which is like eight hours from
seattle i did the gig and just flew to
[ __ ] seattle
and uh
it was weird i left and i was a broken
man i was heartbroken of what had
happened they took my daughter you know
i was broke all i had going for me was i
really really wanted to do comedy you
know something i finally after all these
years beside coke
there was something i really really
wanted to do and i would risk my life
for at this point
and i was frustrated because you want to
get good you want things to happen and
nothing happens it's a slow process and
i was at the three-year mark the
four-year mark that's where you go crazy
and nothing was happening and finally
the phone rang in january and it was
dribble and he goes hey
of the 95. he goes hey i got a gig for
you if you do well
i'll open the books for you and he did
then he kept opening up for me like
three four weeks i got you know that's
how i i did dribble runs all the way to
i moved to seattle even then i did
triple run still
2000 was my last triple run wow but
sometimes you just want to get really
good you want to work on a half hour you
got to do a triple run yeah it's five
nights a week you drive you got a lot of
time to think you're not settled there's
no comfort zone you're [ __ ] gone you
know the rooms suck
but that's what makes you a better comic
you know
so when i left i had all these things
going on nothing was going on and i was
a broken man
i get back to the club i headlined it
that i got banned from
so i left the criminal and came back a
headliner wow you know and i didn't
realize it till i got on stage that
night and i went back to my room and it
was so hard to digest that i didn't
sleep all [ __ ] night now like i'm
like how did this happen
that was all the dream no it was that
what's that song by the talking heads
you may find yourself you know and
living in a shotgun shack well you might
have like how did i get here and that
happens to me once every 90 days i'm
driving i'm surprised because i asked
you before you left you didn't seem like
it was [ __ ] with you that much but
once
i started walking around and once i got
to the club i said wait a second i got
thrown out of here
and i got thrown out of here when i was
down which is even worse when you get
thrown out when things like i got thrown
out and i registered me i
immediately registered that
i wasn't going to get nowhere in denver
i was going to work mckelvey's and wit's
end and they were like 2d rooms
and they didn't like it dirty the one
room was christian i wasn't going to go
nowhere i mean whitson paid 800 a week
to headline
and they gave you an old station wagon
to drive around town so if you didn't
have a car
you know
they stayed in the condo it was horrible
mckelvey's paid like a grand
to headline tuesday the [ __ ] sun i
wasn't going nowhere yeah so i took off
i said if you're not the con i have to
comedy works there ain't no reason to be
in them if you can't work the comedy
worse
and it was just weird to go back and
some of my friends came like uh uh then
the other side of the token was the guys
i hung out with were always chasing [ __ ]
the people i hang out with were salesmen
so they were always chasing for the
better sales job you know
they would go from car dealing and then
when they get mad at car dealing they go
sell
stocks or investments and then when they
get mad at that they go sell fishing
poles and they were always chasing
ten thousand dollars more yeah but is
the air on yeah oh it's [ __ ] warm in
here but
you're gonna turn it up yeah turn it up
a little bit turn that [ __ ] up
those mushrooms are settling in
me too
and that's what would kill me on the
other side that if i wouldn't have tried
comedy in satin boulder i would have
been one of those guys i have nothing
against them right but right now they're
my age and they're probably making 80
000
and they're working six days a week if
they would have stayed at the same
dealership
and crunched their legs in right now
they would have making a hundred grand
the year just showing up because all
those old deals come back to you after
five four years absolutely so there's a
great life lesson no they all travel
they remember life is all uh what what's
that expression grass is always green on
the other side but it really [ __ ]
isn't you know sometimes i tell people
this all the time
sometimes people come to me and go you
know what man
i'm
selling encyclopedias but i'm not making
the money i want
okay
so what are you gonna do lee well i
think i'm gonna get a part-time job to
supplement my income so
you're gonna sell encyclopedias from
eight to five on the phone and then
you're gonna go supplement your another
income job why don't we do this
why don't you go to the [ __ ] uh
uh a bookstore and buy the harvey
lembeck or whatever the [ __ ] guy's
name is it teaches you how to sell
there's always a book in there always
that teaches people how to sell
and you get on that [ __ ] phone or
whatever the [ __ ] you're selling and you
stick it out and you keep cause what
these guys are doing or moving around
every 90 days persistence and this is
[ __ ] i'm you know i've been doing
comedy 24 [ __ ] years so these guys
have been moving like when my friend
came to see michael you're still at
whatever honda goes no that was five
years ago i went to investments then i
went to sell wine door-to-door and i'm
like you know i had insane on tumblr
that night when i got home i did the
sign of the cross and i said how [ __ ]
lucky am i that [ __ ] 50 i'm still not
moving from dealership to dealership
oh my god well what are you so blessed
what happens because i i've heard both
of you guys talk like what happens for
comedians and actors who have to move
change like management and agency
because you have to like you outgrow it
at a certain point but then like you
ever worry like oh maybe i'm making the
mistake i i knew this guy like it must
be kind of weird like there's a bunch of
variations but what happens is
you know sometimes an agent retires okay
sometimes you'll get a call and say this
guy's like i'm leaving the business but
sometimes you get an agent that calls
you and says i'm going to a different
agency and they bring a few people with
them and you know so now you have to
wherever you tell no to is going to be
mad at you you don't win you know you
don't win right yeah you have to tell
somebody some people don't give a [ __ ]
about it i do because i get involved
with them because
i feel that when i get involved with an
agent he'll work for me a little bit
more personally yeah because they have
to have with them it happens with like
every time i left a job i'd be like [ __ ]
like even even but before college like
when i was working at cvs every time i
left like i went to go to the movie
theater and i hated the movie theater
the first couple days it's like you
worry about like made the wrong choice
so i can see where your friends are
coming from you never listen once you go
you [ __ ] go
once you go you go you don't look back
there's no wrong choice if you do uh uh
what's an educated guess
estimate a hypothesis whatever you know
after dom
i thought it out when i got the call
that thursday i thought it out i sat
down all week and i was somewhere and i
did the [ __ ] abe lincoln clothes and
yeah the pros and the cons and i thought
it out and i knew
the major decision was some of these
feelings were gonna get hurt yeah if i
stayed at one place i was gonna hurt the
one guy and if i stayed the other place
i was gonna hurt the one guy yeah so you
know sometimes you gotta remember it's
your agent who got you there ari made a
good point because i called arm and he
goes when i was at warrior gym when when
what's his name left they called me and
said so now we're ready to go to work
lawrence who left and he's like why i'm
not staying i've had lawrence since day
one he's the one that got me all this
work i can't just [ __ ]
can him and stay yeah that's why i don't
like agencies where you sign across the
board with somebody because now you're
[ __ ] for everything else yeah so you
want to go with aqua for commercials you
want to go with caa for bookings you
want to go with you know fountain blue
[ __ ] agency
so that doesn't happen that's why people
say when you go across the board it's a
bad
thing it makes sense i never thought
about it like that but it's true
but limit yourself but it's just weird
how this uh this thing happened this
weekend it was full [ __ ] circle
and you sit there and
you know that night i thought about did
i ever think of this happening
not in a million years i always thought
maybe i'd get better at doing comedy but
i didn't think the comedy works would
take me back so
i'm proud that they did i'm really happy
they had some great shows great people
came you know how that club is bro
that club's a [ __ ] monster that club
and if somebody's high energy and loud
that club is built for them yes because
it's low ceilings and [ __ ] yes
you know i had great sets i had to work
with steve mcgrew who was a [ __ ]
killer to follow
but he lifted the room he just took him
out of the [ __ ] dregs he's such a
brilliant comic you know
worked with a couple guys i worked with
rick kearns i hadn't seen rick in 20
years i know he's not i don't know if i
ever worked with him but i know that
name rick is the rick was a guy that i
looked up to more than todd jordan todd
jordan was helping me but rick didn't
give a [ __ ] rick threw bottles of
people's faces ricky threw drinks at
people's faith you know first time i got
a call from rick we're working for bill
bower not while bill bowell was dead
bill bowe was a skier that booked rooms
in colorado great heart of a guy if it
wasn't for him i couldn't pay my rent a
couple because i would call him and go i
can't pay rent can you front me the
money and then just give me gigs and he
do it all the time that's how cool he
was wow so rick called me one day
because hey i need for you to uh pick me
up uh
any feeder do this open for me i'll give
you 200 but part of that 50 is for
driving you got to drive so i'm going to
forget he got to my house he's like you
take the keys stop at a liquor store you
know first thing is first emptied out a
[ __ ] gatorade put vodka in it we
drank that all the way up to rivets in
wyoming and i was like lee there was no
saying no to rick kearns you don't tell
lee like no i don't feel like drinking
[ __ ] i used to drink with him because i
knew he wouldn't stop
and we'd do these gigs and we'd write
together and he just
he was uh the opposite of todd jordan
was very professional very on time wore
nice rick kearns was he was dirty he
yelled at club by owners then he went to
when i moved to seattle he goes i'll
help you any way you could because he
take he took fourth in in uh sf san
francisco comedy competition wow in like
85 so i was up there in the 80s uh
knowing
the [ __ ] am i talking he wanted like a
95.
i was in seattle in 96 where he told me
that he gave me all the references to
call fox and everything but he got
arrested in chattanooga for going to
bike crack
and they threw him in the cell and they
sprayed him he
cursed the cops and he fought him so
they sprayed him with mace and they put
him in the hole and every time the sun
shine on him it would kick up the mace
ah and he would be in there crying and
scratching [ __ ] i sent the money in
jail
and he came out and he got a great radio
gig and then he was writing for the
puppet
from vegas the one that won america's
oh uh he was the i
met guy right yeah artistic director
jeff not for jeff dunham the other no no
no the other guy some guy with a pup
like a hand puppet yeah that guy killed
it yes the guy killed it
you know he's just a great guy now he's
rotting for on white and he writes for
uh yeah he's a great great he charges
three bills an hour i think it's 300 a
joke
and like 5 000 a bit or something
wow it's crazy
what is that like is that a lot for i
never knew what people charge i don't
even know what people charge like how
have you ever tried to think about what
you would charge for it like not
not that you would ever write but like
since a lot of your day is spent writing
and like not making like a salary like
have you thought about how much writing
makes you
no no that's a problem that's a
completely different animal to get
involved in yeah that's a complete
different album because if you're right
now you're going to get the writing
agent right and you always got to write
for free for a while you got to write
for free i just meant like you're
writing like how much you think it's
worth like garbage really garbage nobody
says joey's a good [ __ ] writer right
so move on with i completely disagree
with that i'm not a good writer i have
more energy no i don't i have more
energy
that's what sells the joke i do smoking
mirrors my friends no it's all tied
together
now
you're such a good writer and your voice
is so unique that's why you don't think
it's good because nobody else in the
world could do it that's how you know
your writing's brilliant because you tap
into what comedy is it's
giving the audience a plus b and then
they make the connection c it's giving
them the dots and then they have to
connect the dots you're a master of that
a mat you and you put that like every
great performer you put that feeling in
somebody's chest it's the whole reason
to use words is to create that feeling
it's not what you say it's what you make
them feel and that's what you kill it i
didn't know of course i watch you and
i'm like oh genius i didn't [ __ ] know
that yeah you're the best that's why
you're the guy
everybody watches trying to embarrass me
i'm sorry i'm not trying i should not
just be quiet
over here in front of my friends and
[ __ ]
you're calling me a deadbeat sometimes
i'm on your show and i just can't
believe i'm here
what the [ __ ] how you doing man what's
going on in your world you talked to
gabriel the boys they showed i just
texted him today about uh some a pro
wrestling article i read been around the
world since easter from easter that
monday i flew to china then i was in
town for a couple days went up to yuck
yucks in calgary the best they love you
up there canadians are my favorite
canadians are crazy the nicest when it
comes to comedy it's in their [ __ ]
blood it's in their blood absolutely
that's the thing with con like
they love it they love it and they love
it when it's crazy and they love it when
it's loud and they they just love it
in town and i'm on the church what's
happening now how long are you uh how
long are you at home for
this is the longest stretch i've had
since the cd came out so since november
i'm in town for like a the next gig i
know for sure i've booked
is the week after fourth of july
la jolla la jolla comedy please already
laughing i'm in san diego again
why don't you just buy a house in san
diego one day i will
jesus christ what are you giggling about
[ __ ] off cuz i just knew like every
he'll ask me like once we got steve
simone and like the last couple weeks i
had to say san diego like you were just
there like a couple like a few months
ago and then like two weeks ago one
night or two so he always just said mr
san diego mr san diego that's his
[ __ ] name he loves it
nobody goes more to san diego than steve
[ __ ] diesel money it's one of the
only good open uh one-nighters you can
get from la right
there's always some somebody's got a
room down there that they'll throw some
cash they got a ton of rooms out there
and they got the the harrah's
monique's book and harrah's they got a
ton of [ __ ] in santa right here and
years ago they had nut in la jolla
and something else oh yeah moon doggies
whatever the hell it was they still do
moon doggies get out of here tuesday
night somebody's got to be booking it
somebody and they had they had three
rooms down there they had uh
the one room i forget the name on monday
so that didn't last long but it was
great
then they had tuesday night moondoggies
then wednesday was the [ __ ] next to
him yes and then you went to that uh
rosita's the mexican place around the
corner
yeah yeah i like it the kind the
carnitas from there are the best
carnitas i've ever had in my [ __ ]
life oh the mexican food in el paso was
so good yeah
it's a whole different path to
candelaria show up
right now mary a big big guy
who was the emcee was just you and
paulie yeah two man
they had a couple good comics in el paso
el paso was a town that i cut my comedy
teeth in and i [ __ ] cut my comedy
teeth and like
i don't work for bart anymore but
i think the last time i went was
when freddie died around 2006
and uh it's amazing i thought it'd be
ten years this month all right yeah ten
years in uh yeah it was a journey like a
week yeah this is it this is it right
now
that's [ __ ] that's the quickest 10
years that cause the longest yard came
out freddie dropped
freddie dropped that june because i
remember i was going somewhere and i
couldn't go to the wake of nothing
we had just done the houston comedy
festival
it's amazing it's been [ __ ] 10 years
august yard was 10 years ago 2005. i
remember visiting you down on the set
goldberg was in the trailer next door
stone cold steve austin's walking by
it's that was the craziest
kevin that came down a couple times yes
yeah i know ari came down a couple times
and you know what that was incredible
for me it was a great experience to turn
you guys on to it like i was watching
this every day
and my head listen the first time i
walked into the table read
my head just i just kept sitting there
going
i wish there was periscope because
nobody's ever gonna believe me
i wish i had periscope right now because
nobody's ever gonna believe
what i'm looking at
nobody i mean nobody coming where i came
from
nobody would believe when i walked into
that room
how
my value in life
was garbage and i felt even more
garbagey
because this one he walked first of all
the guy when the limo pulled up adam
sandler greeted me
said let me take that and took my
luggage he had flip-flops on a pair of
shorts wow and i'll never forget looking
at this guy going so this isn't your
get-up just in movies this is your get
up in real life you just don't care like
you had a flannel shirt on and some
broken swim trunks yeah and some [ __ ]
up sneakers on and he picked up my hey
great to have you come on let's go
upstairs and i went upstairs and there's
a table
like a [ __ ] table like a spread like
a last supper yeah packed with food and
all those savages are eating the food
and they're bringing them dishes it's
paramount they're bringing in dishes and
they're like go help yourself and i took
like a piece of sam i had
and i've told this story before i had i
don't know maybe 10 bucks 25 bucks i had
enough for a pack of cigarettes i had
maybe three or four joints maybe two
joints wow and i had enough to tip the
[ __ ] yeah i tipped the limo driver five
bucks
i mean that's all i had i'm sorry and
he's like don't worry about these people
take care of me
and i had like 20 bucks and i went in
and i'm sitting here going what are
these people gonna ask me how much money
i have or something yeah yeah they were
eating at first they were eating when i
got there so i just went over and picked
it and the first head i saw was
romanowski and i just put my head back
down then i looked up again there was
the big uh indian with
warriors when i saw warriors come out to
play yay oh yeah in the room
i i couldn't even look up and even i'm
like these guys are going to fire me
they're doing a background check as we
speak
wow i mean i couldn't vote this is just
and then brett reynolds like hey how you
doing i'm like okay you know he's like
sit down next to me come on boy stand
next to me let's do this together now so
i had him
irving wow i had irvine to one side i
had irvine to the left of me and [ __ ]
birth to the right of me
i had nick the tour across from me i had
warriors come out to play and i had uh
kevin nash that's who was right
and i kept looking for my scene you know
like you gotta yellow it and then yeah
yeah
every time i had to speak i was like
what are they gonna fire me
yeah and then when i walked out they go
they go smith is they're gonna go oh
there you go they're gonna fire me they
go hey you gotta go to the doctor for a
physical and you have to go sign your
contract we'll only sign you for four
weeks oh my god that was the deal i was
gonna something was gonna happen at the
prison to me yeah i wasn't gonna be able
to play something but after i was there
for one week they paid me to do
who gods
wow i would take the [ __ ] limo no
they gave me a rental car i would take
the rental car down and eat their lunch
wow i don't like that lunch at one i
would go right down they eat the [ __ ]
chicken the rice and beans the first
couple weeks we did everything at the
high school gym and the tables were like
you know they're [ __ ] professional
football players they want to eat
everything i mean that was everything
yeah eggs oatmeal you know it was
everything a little bit of everything
yeah
and
i would go there and eat and see these
guys and go ah they gotta fire me the
first week when i didn't work oh my god
i was in my room going they know
they know i kidnapped somebody they're
getting the paperwork ready right now
for a week every time i got high i was
getting paranoid they didn't want to
fire me then the second week i didn't
work monday but tuesday i did something
we did the we were going to kill the
guards who were going to rip the guards
and then we did the opening scene
meatball whatever
for whatever what's the line i say
something which one the from beginning
the first line i'm gonna try out
football
football triats football tryouts
then the next day i did
the stomach
they put me and they're like go just
talk and i'm like don't you [ __ ] cut
me [ __ ] suckers but you can't take [ __ ]
don't you cut me you [ __ ] you can't say
you [ __ ] story don't you cut me [ __ ]
like
i was out in the rain and that scene
they had me on a time it's so weird how
you don't see it they had me on a tarp
and it was [ __ ] about to pour
and they're like joey what do you think
i'm like let's shoot this [ __ ] i
kept shooting it and they're like go and
adam and chris rock are howling they're
on the sides [ __ ] howling and i'm
like you [ __ ] don't [ __ ] cut
me you [ __ ] and i do it again do it
again do it again then the [ __ ] sky
blew up and we all ran to the trailers
and [ __ ] we're all in and they're all
giggling at me hit me i thought like
that was gravy now everybody in the set
was talking to me
yeah everybody in the set was like now
you did the job yeah yeah yeah now
before you can't say nothing until you
rock them you can't say none you got to
sit there like you're [ __ ]
once i did that you should have heard
him bam joey [ __ ] we were dying even
nick was like oh so now it's raining but
i mean not regular raining the sky is
black type deal and we go to our
trailers and they go don't leave just
stay in the trailers we don't want to
drive in this weather
so once it's cooled down they used to
have a hut where they would bring
all the film to it and everybody the
producers would watch the dailies yeah
and when i walked out guys i must i
never said this nobody i could hear them
laughing and i said to myself
that's a shame i only have two ten more
days on this set
they didn't give me a chance to show
them what i could really do once i get
warmed up and not comfortable and now
and when i got they said go eat dinner
and we'll talk to you
and at dinner they came and go adam
wants to see you and i go [ __ ]
and when i walk to adam he gave me a
piece of paper and he goes sign that
they're going to extend you for 17 more
weeks
congratulations wow
and we gave you a raise i'm gonna put
you on the f series you're in
i always like ideas in my eyes what's f
series f series means it's like a sag
contract with a it's a ensemble cast
oh so if you're part of an ensemble cast
they have different shooting things like
you have to show up every day even if
you don't work
there was a lot of little variables that
they could unless you had permission not
to be there you know
so it was just amazing i went back to my
trailer and started crying i was like
this is not happening
this isn't [ __ ] happening you know
the next day i got there and they
already had the welcome suit
they had like a camera for me
you know i mean adam went you know
is this sweet yeah it was like a
thousand bucks it was like t-shirts and
underwear and brand new socks and a
camera
accessories for your cell phone i mean
he went all out they had tons of [ __ ] to
give you wow and uh but that was the
story man and then i would bring you
guys when we were here that wasn't in
new mexico if i could have brought you
guys to new mexico your head really
would have blown up because they had
umbrella girls they went to albuquerque
and hired strippers for 200 cash a day
to come and put them up decline all the
football players were [ __ ] them and
tormenting them
to put them up up at uh
so they would come every day and just
stand with them brothers and bikinis and
shot pants and
wow and you were assigned a [ __ ]
umbrella girl
crazy crazy and anytime you move they
move with you
that's why it's always like this movie
cost 100 million to produce you know we
have umbrella girls you're [ __ ]
umbrella girls that's insane that's
insane so when we brought you when i got
you up to it like i had to show people
this and i didn't want to show just
anybody like i wanted to show my blood i
want to show comics who i really
believed in because
let me tell you something man i don't i
if i wouldn't have done a warm-up to
that movie i would have gotten fired i
tell people there's two projects that i
should have gotten fired from that
there's no way i could have come to the
general hospital fired
fired if i would have came here and they
got whether i would have got general
hospital from the jump fire that's
one-on-one acting that's where you don't
talk to nobody
they give you paperwork at the gate hi
boom they give you an envelope they tell
you what room to go and they go keep
your eye on the wall because there's
like you know a stock of stock exchange
yeah it just moves it says scene 38 come
to the stage for rehearsal they don't
[ __ ] that you can't be on the stage you
just have to sit in your room dressed
wow and there's a microphone and a like
a thing and they'll go
uh scene 44 coming for rehearsal you got
to go in there rehearse the scene go put
your clothes on and you go back in there
and they ain't no cuts there's no
nothing let's say the line is
i [ __ ] you in the ass mildred and you
[ __ ] everything up except mildred they
go pick it up in the top
and don't say i [ __ ] in the ass no do
you they want you to pick it up from
where you [ __ ] up the line uh that's
how professional they are they speed
along they don't have time they don't
have time to stop and train you
it's a three-camera shoot against the
wall
so they're just moving they're just
moving so they call you up and they're
like joe are you ready yeah see they
don't even call you by your name scene
34 come out for rehearsal
all right we'll see you guys go back to
your room and change we'll look up the
teleprompter scene 24 come back and
shoot you go up there
there's no turnarounds there's no
let's do this let's do a halt from the
top go sit down for 45 minutes no no no
no
they [ __ ] burn right through the
scenes when you go in there you rehearse
that [ __ ] you run back you put
your clothing on and you come back i
already got fired from that and i got
fired from the longest show i probably
got that like right right away yeah i
couldn't handle it there's no way there
was so many variables the acting like
you have to remember tattoos what
tattoos you got and where cause they
don't know they just give the [ __ ]
guy a package every morning
okay so you have to tell them no it's
right [ __ ] there so you have to know
exactly for the cameron and some of the
pas will come and [ __ ] with you bro you
gotta go do that tattoo over it's too
close to your knuckle and they'll have
pictures from yesterday and go look at
where it was yesterday
yeah it was there was a lot of little
things i couldn't get [ __ ] used to
and plus my insecurities just your
insecurity alone you know it's not a
movie with four college kids right this
is chris looking at you and [ __ ] you
know reynolds uh what's the other guy
you know the guy got into the car
tracy morgan all these [ __ ] people
you can't [ __ ] when they say all right
ready joey yeah action there's 200
people watching kind of deliver this
isn't [ __ ] 10 people in a room
there's 200 people going come on joey
and you're like
it's like a [ __ ] fist fight it's like
going to school play you know so it was
i wouldn't have made it so when i
brought you guys i wanted you guys i
didn't bring i only brought you an army
wow
you ari and maybe there was two other
people dave crowded marilyn's husband i
told brett reynolds that he was a
probation officer that's how i got him
on the set like you're on probation for
what don't worry about it what's his
name
and reynolds got him and gave him an air
beaten for like three hours about why he
wanted to go into law enforcement so
when dave left there he was dave looks
down on me from heaven everything goes
joey's all right no matter what happened
because i took him on that set and fed
him he ate at the [ __ ] luncheon you
ain't doing oh it was amazing oh you
introduced me to bert rounds first
person you introduced me to did that
uncle burt here's steve simone of the
philadelphia simones
and then you got him to start telling
steve mcqueen's stories about him and
steve mcqueen at the formosa oh my god
and i'm like this is this happening so
then that happens and we're having
laughs you're making burt reynolds
the whole time so then so then adam
sandler comes over and adam sandler's
like wanted to be in the mix with you
and burt reynolds and i'm going what am
i doing here don't say anything don't
say anything
and then you introduce me as a comic and
then sandler told me a story about when
he had a big huge showcase at the ice
house and he bombed and forgot
everything and he was like joey we're
making movies now he goes it's so much
easier than stand-up comedy and i went
oh where am i
where am i oh my god i remember it all
you know i love when uh
i love decent people i love like league
when i call lee and tell him i'm gonna
[ __ ] you up [ __ ] we're doing
heroin and when he does oh my god he
knows i'm giggling in the background
yeah
when adam when you went up to adam and
you know told him your story like adam
hold on one second here's the script let
me talk to you adam would look at me and
i could tell he was enjoying it
hey why he was enjoying it because i
know i was rubbing a lot of people wrong
but he loved me
do you follow me like that's why he
loved me even more yeah because he knew
i was rubbing the [ __ ] producer wrong
he knew the director hated me he knew
the other producer hated me he knew like
everybody was like we don't know we
should take joe diaz and he's like i'm
gonna give this fat [ __ ] a shot i'll
watch him personally with my nutsack
fought on my shorts first person that
came home and said put that speed bag
how cool is that most people come up
here what the [ __ ] are you not decent
adam was howling adam and joe rogan are
the same person
you know when they're in the room
serious and people like listen joe you
really gotta team it down with joey joe
goes crazy yeah you go why why you got
you better team at that why
that guy is [ __ ] fun to have you know
joe goes on
and that's how adam that day when i went
to adam sound like oh he's talking all
these [ __ ] industry people we're in
it's the day nelly's album went double
platinum he sold the
the two albums the same sentence
whatever yes and he had that uh brand
new rolls royce or bentley you have no
idea lee this is all going on on this
day so they come in that morning and say
to us hey
now this is all the people from the
movie and we're in that's the scene i
took my pants off right i walked back
and i'm like i'm not dressing for this
and they're like you have to you have to
and i waited until everybody left the
room i didn't argue i knew exactly how
to get what i wanted i knew exactly how
to get how i wanted adam
i didn't [ __ ] around with nobody else i
went right to adam and fought my case
like they wanted me to smoke and i was
like yeah come here i ain't smoking who
said you lose them you do what you want
joey don't bother me
that he loved it the day he gave me the
microphone you know it was him that gave
me the microphone with all those kids
there and then he ran away and i could
see him in the background
howling like a kid
dante
don't give joey the microphone don't
give him the microphone i don't know if
i know this story wouldn't happen it was
crowd the crowd the crowd warm up you
know when the crowd warm-up comes in
there's a warm-up yeah so they're like
dante knew me so me and dante are
[ __ ] around i guess they went to
dante and said
when you pass that mic around don't give
it to joey dears
adam took it from dante and gave it to
jerry beers and he's like goddamn
through five minutes and people like
shut it down shut them down they're
grabbing kids and item is like feed him
go he's loving it with his little
[ __ ] meme machine [ __ ] i'll never
forget it he was loving it and then when
they came back in the game the thing he
goes don't [ __ ] them because don't worry
about them because i told them when you
that's the one who he gave me that
moniker he goes listen as soon as you
walk in the room the room becomes rated
they all knew that [ __ ] him and he
walked away from me wow that's how cool
that man was that's how cool anybody
listen that's why when people talk about
adam sandler like his movies not about
his movies man it's how he treats people
you know freddie what because freddy
soto did the movie with him after me
yeah spanglish spanglish so freddie went
to the premiere with adam and freddie
called me the next day it was dog
i asked him he goes i didn't want to ask
him during the movie
but i asked him at the at the thing
about what do you think of my man joey
diaz and he goes hold on one second he
goes where did that [ __ ] come he
stole my movie i go he gonna see that he
[ __ ] came on that set
and he was high-fiving people i mean you
know after a month i ran that yeah yeah
i heard my own uniforms everybody would
give me massages
you know you had guys picking us up on
golf carts on golf carts gators
no he'll take you to he'll get something
did they give you gators did they give
you guys guys me up with gators on yeah
and i go what is this because romanowski
had a gator company so he was giving
those shoes to everybody and he gave the
gay guy a pink one romanowski don't [ __ ]
around he hated that kid he gave him
pink [ __ ] you had roma oh
romo i got a big eagles fan over here
you you introduced me to everybody
i brought now did i bring you arie the
day burt reynolds hit the touchdown to
win the game was it baltius or was it
ahri because ari said he was right i was
right there oh my god that's [ __ ]
reynolds i had to call my father it was
[ __ ] surreal and now i i never wanted
you to go on the set and go
this is [ __ ] i was on the longest show
these [ __ ] are punk ass [ __ ]
compared to what i saw oh i remember
telling people when i got back to the
comedy store they were like i forgot who
it was they were like
oh really was that and i go you don't
understand and they told everybody that
me and you got into a chicken fight with
adam sandler burt reynolds i was i was
on your shoulders and bert ross was on
adam sandler's shoulders
and people were like no way it was the
best it was the best he really
you know i think adam like i watch adam
in other movies now and like the other
day zohan was on yesterday people didn't
like that's great i love that i watched
it because it's a pretty good one yeah i
watched it because it was adam because i
was thinking how i went to audition
and i wrote them a lot if i want work
all i had to do was write out them sound
like a letter like i haven't seen him in
two years he just finished a cowboy
movie oh cool i'm writing him a letter
next week i've been thinking about it
for like a month it's time for an adam
sandler letter so maybe his next movie's
in hawaii because he shoots all those
[ __ ] movies in hawaii too you know
genius they're gonna shoot the longest
yard in a while i think they would have
been
but then they couldn't figure out how
they were gonna cgi the trees oh my god
that was the problem they didn't know
how they were gonna get rid of the
[ __ ] palm trees
really no that's why i
brought it's weird we're still friends
[ __ ] 12 years later and
i had the utmost respect i knew you were
gonna do something with your life i just
wanted you to see that
so you could see what i was seeing
through my eyes and
for that whole shooting i was waiting to
die
i'm not gonna lie to any of you guys i
was waiting a building to fall on me
and i was ready to accept it i was i was
that far
i was such a loser for such a long time
this didn't put me in a high i never
looked at it like that's that to me is
the depth no no i looked at it as
uh
i'd been i had
nothing had been working out for me for
so long so when i got this it was
i felt like something was gonna happen
like i was gonna die of a heart attack i
kept thinking the building was gonna
fall on me i remember laughing in
in uh santa fe going
when is this building gonna fall on me
it's only five floors it's not gonna
happen here it's gonna happen in that
layer
yeah it's not a [ __ ] regular one it's
like a piano it's gonna fall on me
it was just too surreal
too it was too surreal to be at a table
the prison table at the end when we're
eating the chicken we got so [ __ ]
high i bought a pound
i bought a pound
for 2 500 miles and brought it with me
it was so good to weed i just brought it
with me i sold half of it to nelly and i
gave the other half to other people
me and nelly and the rest of us
were so [ __ ] stoned now what's the
quarterback from the other team
he hates weed
they put him in nellie's trailer by
mistake
and somebody he had smoked weed and then
he got pissed he didn't like drugs so we
we went out of our way to torment that
[ __ ] guy uh that's a star the
quarterback but that that scene
we got so high
we ate so much chicken
they had to send out and get more
stuffing that's what we were eating
whatever we were eating in that thing
all the cranberry sauce
we ate the [ __ ] ten cans of cranberry
sauce oh they kept saying how can
cranberry sauce yeah delicious we were
so [ __ ] stoned we ate the cranberry
sauce everything that scene we were
there for a day that scene what made
that scene even better was that
uh
[ __ ] uh we just mentioned he was next
to me when he ripped the door off the
trailer what was his name yeah goldberg
goldberg goldberg is good friends with
the tv host from chicago maury povich i
don't know huh
so he did this uh sorry about that
people i'm trying to
not make the bottle and so he did a
benefit he brought kids that day
like you know a hundred homeless kids or
something maury povich yeah we're
wrecked and goldberg we're wrecked
we're stoned to the gills
and these kids are walking around and
asking us [ __ ] creepy questions how
do i get into stand up
it's just amazing i remember hugging
this little black
just
i couldn't where i had been i had never
seen anything like that you know i had
done a move with james colburn i'd done
little things or i'd done spider-man 2
already when i got that movie
but nothing impacted me
like the first month of the longest shot
i walked around and didn't do it i
didn't do blow
at all in santa fe until the last week
where i took that little chick home that
sucked the bottles that tracy morgan
kept asking if she wants a black baby
that [ __ ] little dirty [ __ ] that's
the only person i did blow with i mean
that that was it i mean i was so
in this zone that this is not happening
this is like my mother dying this is not
happening this dream i'm gonna wake up
out of this dream and they gotta fire me
but you know uh
it was just a good preparation like it
really uh
it was amazing i remember now in
hindsight i look back at stuff like that
i remember was joe rogan that told me
that he goes fame comes to you in stages
and he was and it was exactly what you
were just saying he said that uh
he was like this has got to be 14 years
ago at the comedy store 12 years ago
he was like
if tomorrow night you got on the tonight
shows there was a fallout and they go
put steve simon on the tonight show he
goes and you killed it he's like you
could kill it right now he goes but that
would be the worst thing in the world
for you because you wouldn't be able to
handle it you would lose your mind he
was like it's got to come to you in
stages because first you're going to
become friends with somebody famous
he was like that's the great thing about
the comedy series like look at it he
goes do you think of me as famous i go i
guess so he goes yeah but it's not a big
deal to you he goes i was just in
florida with joey diaz we were in the
mall and people go there's the guy from
news radio this was even before ufc blew
up and he goes we got chased in the mall
he goes they didn't know how to handle
seeing somebody famous he goes but now
we're friends he goes i'm not joe rogan
from tv i'm just joe to you and i'm like
yeah and then he said
he goes now that's the first
first level there's the second stage he
goes one of your friends
and i remember ren is easy and ari were
there he goes one of these guys it could
be him could be one of these guys one of
your friends is going to become famous
and he goes and that's what's going to
trip you out you're going to start going
wait we're working the door at the
comedy store together and now he's
making movies and he goes and that's
what you need he goes because then it
starts to seem normal to you you get
exposed to it without the pressure of
performing he was like and then what's
gonna happen is you're slowly gonna
start to become famous and not even
realize it he's gonna because because
when one of your best friends is
shooting a movie
you're pissed that you just got to do
the tonight show you're gonna go yeah i
did the tonight show but i should have
done that tonight show five years ago so
it's all gonna be behind where you think
you're supposed to be and he goes and
that's how it seems normal to you he
goes and that's why you're making movies
but you're really thinking about what
are you going to produce next you don't
even think acting in a movie is a big
deal and i'm like that's jesus it's true
and it's so true
you know when i came out here i never
expected big things i never expected i i
knew what i didn't want to be
i knew that's important i didn't want to
be seinfeld i knew i always wanted to be
a character
in a big show let them you know uh
what's the show with the gay guy
grace
will and grace will engrave those that
show is not about those two moks i like
them both
that show is about the the chick the
alcoholic the little short girl
i never saw that oh oh she's tortured i
never saw him she was [ __ ] tremendous
she was really good it was it was their
show but it was her and jack yeah who
[ __ ] demolished that show i mean she
demolished that show she was everything
a character wanted to be rich a drunk
married to a 70 year old guy or her
comments us a drunk [ __ ] everything
is she's just a drunk with vodka
she made that show but nobody gave her
credit i did children's hospital with
her and i saw her running in the halls
and doing the clown [ __ ] i walked up on
my list and
that [ __ ] diamond greg whatever or
grace and slick whatever will grace you
[ __ ] rock that she's like thank you i
mean you really rocked it wow i'm gonna
have to go back and watch it oh she
kills the dog she [ __ ] kills it every
episode she was the episode that's
always the show her and the mexican made
yeah the mexican [ __ ] made were
[ __ ] brilliant brilliant together so
that's like your ideal role yes
just come on the show and let me go
[ __ ] crazy let somebody else be their
name on the thing
let them do all that i don't i want that
i never wanted that guy i never wanted
to sit in the [ __ ] bmw i never wanted
to walk into a [ __ ] comedy club eight
deep
that's yeah yeah yeah
those things are not necessary to me i
don't judge my manhood by me driving a
beam and throwing keys out of valet
right i see the attitude i don't not
like beamers because i don't like them
because people get this different
attitude when they drive a beamer
especially here yes you know they don't
even you make all this money and you
have all these options to buy a car but
you go by this beamer because that's
what the stat you know that's always
bothered me yep you know when i did a
lot of movies when i go to the studios i
see all these lines up in beavers same
cars beamers like nobody has any
creativity like they all want to be part
of the same [ __ ] gang yeah [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that's why a beam and then to what
to spend sixty thousand to do thirty
five go [ __ ] your mother yeah i gotta
get a [ __ ] bean but hey if i do
ninety in the subaru can you imagine
wanna do the [ __ ]
you know i mean it's uh
i was thinking about what's going on
with you and your life right now
right now
you're a rocket ship
with all the right people sitting it but
they haven't loaded the gun powder in it
yeah like you're ready to take off it's
just a matter of
it's like when you go to a airport and
they're behind there's 15 flights yeah
it's whenever your plane takes off
because you never really know what's
going on but you can always see a guy
that's doing the right choices
i didn't know
then but i know now that for some reason
in all my cocaine when we were [ __ ]
around in vegas with tj and dj
that i still
was making good choices as a comic i was
still trying i knew that i wasn't gonna
make it as a comic i [ __ ] knew it i
knew that what i wanted wasn't gonna
come to me as a comic so i went through
the back door it's funny how all these
people on twitter hit me and they go
joey i'm watching you on base i didn't
know that was me guy i've been [ __ ]
at this for 10 years sure i've been at
this for 18 years okay
nothing i could always see when i smell
somebody who's looking for a quick hit
i i know when somebody approaches me and
they have their nose wide open you can
always tell when somebody's walking into
a room and their nose is wide open you
didn't come to the store with me last
week
or the week before you missed this girl
the other night that
and i always said i was
i wanted to be funny
i always wanted to be funnier than being
famous
to me i wanted to be funny
to be [ __ ] famous [ __ ] all that [ __ ]
earn your black belt i wanted to be
wanted to be a band i wanted to learn i
watched i love lucy i watched the
honeymoon as i watched jack benny i
watched comedy from every [ __ ] level
to be funny to take a little piece from
those people it's not a joke a nod from
their eye i watched jeff i watched you
know the other day i was on the phone
with donna and i explained to dom how
many times i watched that rodney special
that he's on with all those famous
comedians
i rented it so much they wouldn't take
my money at the [ __ ] video store no
more wow nobody else was writing that
[ __ ] movie when i was writing it but
i rented it so much that they were like
joel we can't take your money no no
thank you you've been you paid for this
movie three four times i you know
i lie to people i tell people that i was
a [ __ ] it wasn't that i was a [ __ ] it
was i was covering my [ __ ] bases
first thing i watched was punchline
with tom hanks yep and then after that
you make the call you buy judy carter
workbook yep you read that then you buy
the gene parade [ __ ] yes and you
read that around a little while right
now in the meantime i wasn't a [ __ ] i
was preparing myself for mary angle just
like jiu jitsu i didn't want to miss a
beat and i'd come back to it later so i
got to rodney dangerfield both of them
with [ __ ] uh
roseanne and hicks and kenneth anderson
and the black guy that made the movie
for four thousand dollars on his credit
card robert townsend he killed it killed
it
big petey little petey where's the pd i
watched
killed on that the only [ __ ] times i
watched that and made notes and cried
and uh
is it on youtube
it's one of the best pieces
rodney dangerfield's comedy special
tweak that in there i had no money at
all no money when i was living with fat
james
and i remember coming off the road with
paulie
one time i bought the rockies there was
five rockies i bought the five rocky
dvds next time i came off the road i
bought the rodney dangerfield they did a
collection of those
and it was all the specials
it is uh it was calm and i'm sorry i
haven't spoken about this earlier it was
comedy 101 for me
uh ronnie dangerfield no respect let's
try that
let's try what happened all right
comedian special there it is
yeah look for rodney young comedian
special
sorry about that guys you really really
if you have not seen this
try in 1884.
oh nelson [ __ ]
have you seen bob nelson lee no all
right so tap them tap them bob right on
top rather the top one that's bob nelson
with the [ __ ] uh the boxing
guillotine you really never seen this
jeff what all right put this on lee for
the people at home
if you've ever wanted to be a
professional boxer
or
just look like one
come on down to jiffy jeff's gym
in new york city
you never saw it literally how to become
a shooting the [ __ ] headset no wait
no you shouldn't be part of this
proprietor of jiffy jeff's jim
jiffy jeff himself to give you a few
free pointers on how to become a
professional fighter
you never saw this no you showed me this
oh
hello welcome to jiffy jeff's gym
uh
my name my name is jess
sorry my name is
i own i own the gym and uh
i'm here to give you a few free
free tips
on the professional fights become a
professional fighter how to become a
professional fighter first of all let me
start off right off the bat
right off the bat let me start off uh
there's a lot of training a lot of
training a lot of training training
training train training every day
training training training but a lot of
training as a matter of fact some of the
guys take the train from their homes
into the day
into the city every day into the city
which is a lot of training itself as
well so you have to trade to trade trade
a trade get a monthly ticket get a
monthly ticket if you take the trade i
have a monthly ticket i don't take the
train but i'm such a [ __ ] bargain
i've got one anyway you know
okay trading that's one now also
you need you you you you v elemental p
choose us
you need a nick you need a nick you need
a you need a nickel you need a nickel i
can't i can't get in my pockets
you need a nickel nickel necklace nick
nicholas nicholas
oh you need a necklace no no a nickname
a nickname yeah that's it if you want to
become a fighter a fighter a fighter
if you want to become a fighter you need
a good nickname okay jerry cootie jerry
cootie dang he's got a good nickname
they call him gentlemen they call him
gentlemen gentlemen gentlemen gentlemen
gentlemen stocks your engines they call
them gentlemen
and uh
do you know why you don't want to call
them gentlemen you know why you don't
why you don't know why you go [ __ ]
idea why
that's a really big thing i did this all
right did there's a marvelous uh it's
marvelous moment haggling you know what
i call it marvelous because he looks
dang
good that's what i call that
i have a nickname i have a nickname they
call me jeff jeff jeff what what what
that's very nice i'm sorry i i thought i
heard somebody calling me anyway hey
call me jeff jeff what what
i'm doing
you're probably looking at me saying
who the hell are you to tell me about
the fine fight game well let me tell you
right now i i've had myself i've had
alcohol alto training i've had alto alto
no a lot a lot of training
i'm sorry i spelt it wrong i smelled the
wrong i'll co a lot
but anyway i have had a lot of training
i was a pro i was a professional fighter
at one time i had one i had one i had
one i had one i had one what what what
what what the [ __ ] do you want oh i'm
talking to you
i had six professional fights six
professional fights of which i lost
11.
[ __ ] story you wanna hear a story
i'll tell you something i i i i i knew i
would i was fighting with marvin i was
sparring you ever spawn with somebody
sparring match they pay you very well
five dollars a shot five dollar shot
every time they hit you boom five
dollars you know
so if you get hit ten times what is that
uh 35 hours
anyway
that's what happened so i'm sparring
with this guy i was fired with i'm
sparring with marvin haggler no barbie
haggling marvin haggling bobbing one of
those [ __ ] guys it doesn't matter
they're quite the same way i forgot
well i don't know anyway
anyway i'm in the ring i'm in the ring
with this guy i'm in the ring right i'm
in the ring i'm gonna do ring i'm gonna
do a ring i'm gonna do regular answer to
the [ __ ] phone
anyway ring with haggler right and he's
he's he he's hitting me he's hitting me
he's hitting me he's hitting me he's
hitting me he's hitting me i'm counting
my money five dollars five dollars five
dollars five dollars five dollars five
dollars
good payday five dollars five dollars
now all of a sudden all of a sudden he
stops hitting me
i'm fighting with the guy all of a
sudden he stops hitting me i'm in the
corner like this coming up like that you
know i can't see him so after about 30
seconds i'm thinking one of two things
either he went home
or he ran out of money
i don't know which you know what i'm
saying so what do i do
this is brilliant guys
physical well written
you know i'm sorry i didn't uh talk
about this for other people who want to
do stand up and start let's see what
else they got on there okay they got who
else do they have uh
look for uh
oh [ __ ] look for andrew guy's clown he
kills it oh he [ __ ] kills you kills
it he follows bill hicks just scroll
that down
right there
you want to do dice clay yeah yeah he
[ __ ] kills this is what made him a
star
you never saw this thing no you showed
me this it's okay no i i don't think
we're watching that
comes from brooklyn okay i'll show you
bill hicks
yeah
and i guess the best way to describe him
is to say he's the typical boy next door
say hello to andrew dice clay okay who's
the gay dude that was cool at the store
i loved him he always showed up with
young boys he's that he opens up the
show he opens one of these up because
there's two of them yeah there are two
guys i like i said i'm sorry go on
amazon and look for
uh rodney's young comedian special if
you want to know comedy 101 because you
got 10 of the best comics of all time to
learn from from lenny clark the [ __ ]
denison at the end yep
and you know hicks had to follow this
[ __ ] animal
[ __ ] follows them great this is just
comedy 101 guys
little miss muffet sat on a tuffet
eating occurred some way
long camera spidey sat down beside he
said hey
what's in the bowl [ __ ]
it's still fine
i wanna just [ __ ] joe went up the
hill both with a buck and a quarter jill
came down with 250.
little boy blue
he needed the money
once an old lady lived in a shoe she has
so many kids a uterus fell out
looking for that laughter mary mary
quite contrary trim that [ __ ] it's so
damn hairy
oh mother hubbard went to the cupboard
to get her old dog bone she bent over
rover took over
she got a bone of her own years ago
like i said if you really get a chance
you should watch this if you're into a
stand up and uh
what did you watch to get you into
stanford this stuff i remember watching
this live i remember me and my brothers
it was
in my parents bedroom
for whatever reason i guess it came on
late at night and we're all
on the floor watching it everybody in
the room together crippled with laughter
i remember dice i remember kennison
coming out and doing the sand bit
why are you eating why are you here uh
yep all that [ __ ] this is sand yeah
nothing grows here it's a [ __ ] desert
yep i remember seeing eddie murphy i
remember i remember my parents going to
see prior when i was three
and i don't know why but i remember i
wanted to go see him
we i grew up in one of those houses
where like you know some families are
like the sports family where they know
everything about sports and the kids are
all athletic and the dads
and then there's other families where
they're nerds or there's other family my
family was the comedy family you could
come over watch rated r movies when i
was nine my parents didn't care i was
watching eddie murphy carlin i remember
seeing the dice and then the special
diceman comments after that oh my god
i'm being in the halfway house
watching that in the [ __ ] halfway
house making them watch that for new
year's eve
yep and i got at that point i knew i'm
like this is what i want to do i want to
do what he's doing because he's saying
half the [ __ ] i'm thinking yes you know
planting your ass and all that [ __ ]
he's saying half the things i'm [ __ ]
thinking anyway so
i want to give this a shot you know dice
really [ __ ] was the one that pushed
me over the ledge yeah i liked rodney i
liked richard pryor but dice was the one
that said wait you know when i watch
richard pry i go
maybe i could do that but when i watched
dice
dice was the convincing thing yes
because my thoughts were like that you
know when people you know what do you
just so many things that my
when i'm walking and i was telling
people on stage the other night your
first reaction is your real reaction
yeah and you guys saw a picture of
caitlyn last week and you said in your
heart jesus christ [ __ ] almighty
that's your first reaction yeah then
your mind
gets that reaction and makes it society
uh forms it so you have an answer so
when you go to starbucks you don't
offend your friends and you don't offend
your co-workers right that's the problem
with society today everybody can't
offend them we can't say what's really
on our mind but your first reaction is
what the [ __ ] is this
yeah what the [ __ ] there's so many
things like that that happened in
today's society that we're not really
[ __ ] thinking about like what the
[ __ ] is this yeah what the [ __ ] is this
you know it even applies to them like a
marijuana business i just went to denver
and i'm like what the [ __ ] is this
you know i like this this is great blah
blah blah but what the [ __ ] is this this
is
this could not be this could not be
happening
what are you guys laughing about
he cleaned the microphone i don't know
there was a piece of [ __ ] something
on there like lint i was just just just
just no i wasn't laughing at that i was
laughing at your reaction like this is
too good to be true
no
listen i look at it from both
perspective when i look at things like
that i am not going to lie to you i'm
not going to lie to you i'm a pot smoker
i've smoked the [ __ ] in 30 something
[ __ ] years am i proud no i'm not
proud of it right there's one part of
that
that i see it
weakening the moral fight i'm not gonna
lie to you interesting you know this
thing with caitlyn that okay he has
female feelings i'm gonna go on the
ledge here he had female feelings and
whatever he had he knew he was a female
i watched the the whatever diane shaw
and it was very touching and i cried
myself i i get in the way what he's
doing yes i don't get the applaud for
this i don't get i think it's a fake
applaud you know again i'm gonna go on
the limb here
uh two guys getting married listen i got
a gay cousin
i have [ __ ] tons of friends that are
gay and i break their balls i call them
[ __ ]
i say it on stage but i have no hatred
for gays or nothing like that but i
gotta tell you something two guys
walking down the street [ __ ] married
some it doesn't bother me it does not
bother me
but i have to ask you
how is lee and his wife that they're
attorneys and their straight-laced
people lee wouldn't curse if he didn't
hang out with me lee wouldn't do half
the [ __ ] things how would him and
paula what would they talk about how
would they tell their son they're gonna
have a nice son or a nice daughter
they're not gonna curse they're not
gonna drink in the house they're two
nice white [ __ ] people how do you
explain to your son at five why jim and
[ __ ] pat are swapped and spit down
the [ __ ] blockers you're gonna see it
you're going to [ __ ] see it your
daughter who is six is gonna go daddy
you told me mommy and daddy it's already
happening in the schools it's happening
so i'm not mad at it but this is
something that america would have said
hey man what the [ __ ] is going on here
this pro and contour i understand you
want a man and you want to make your
[ __ ] statement but i still gotta
[ __ ] tell people i still gotta talk
to six-year-olds that can't comprehend
that type of [ __ ] yeah
i always listen i saw one
shoot
whatever at eight
i'm telling you right here guys did it
affect me in a lot of ways i do not know
if you talk to psychiatrists it did
affect me somewhere
you know did it give me pts i don't know
i don't know but this oh this morning's
episode also on the sopranos very
interesting i got up early this morning
we're up to season three
just for long we haven't watched it in
five or six years okay great when you
haven't it's just that's what i did i go
let me turn these on wow
and that episode also is when anthony
figures out why he started fainting when
he goes to saturials and they take that
reality in the back and they cut his
finger off
okay he cut his finger off he's fine he
gets in the car he goes home the guy who
plays his father
great it's [ __ ] great have you seen
him yet no more
he was in
uh he was in carlito's way he's the
brunette that chases
carlito to the train at the end get him
he's the son he's the son he's what's
his name both of them him and the guy
who plays young junior are in carlito's
way
i got it that was a good movie i got to
go back this way it's a very [ __ ]
good movie but uh
what do you call that what are we
talking about sopranos
how the uh the childhood incident
affected him so he went to sanctuary
hours he was a the reason why they owned
saturday owls is because san trial
killed himself
it's a great interesting story that's
saturated he killed himself because he
owed
bookie money he owed he lost the shop
to gambling and then that's why the
sopranos took it over tony took it over
he owns that whatever
but then he goes home and that's when
his father calls him over and says come
here most guys would have ran away like
a little girl
you handled it nothing happened to you
i'm proud of you but remember don't go
don't go get older and gamble he breaks
it down for me because that i know you
like mr satrell and he's a good man
but he has a very bad problem to gamble
he doesn't honor his bets and the man
honors his debts
and he breaks it down i mean you just
cut off some guy's [ __ ] finger you're
breaking it down for your kid and poor
young tony's like yeah whatever then
they go in the kitchen and he cut the
roast yeah and as he's cutting the roast
that's the first time he fainted and
they got four stitches
you know so and then dr melfi tells them
how it affected them blah blah blah blah
blah
i don't know i you know i i just don't
know how that should affect you yeah you
know how it's gonna affect the
seven-year-old walking down the street
and saying i just saw two guys
and this might not happen in their
lifetime maybe i'm exaggerating maybe
i'm over whatever but these are little
topics that in my world i gotta say to
me and i'm telling you even the [ __ ]
marijuana all this free marijuana [ __ ]
was not something i was into
this legalizing marijuana it's not
something i was into i appreciate the
money it's making all this yeah and i
smoke dope with three hands but i didn't
like what it would do to the moral
fabric i didn't like it
interesting i didn't like it there's a
lot of things that are against moral
fabric that are against what we believe
yeah i went to prison i [ __ ] up and i
paid my debts right and i was against my
own moral fabric okay see you're hitting
on a huge topic that i i don't talk
often about but the problem is
not messing up isn't a problem we're all
human we're all gonna
make mistakes
but at least you know when you make a
mistake our moral compass in this
country is so gone gone people do not
know when they're being rude people do
not know when they're making mistakes
people do not care i see how people park
to change i want the jiu jitsu this
morning selfishness 22 people [ __ ]
parking eight inches nine feet from the
other guys i think that should be a
ticket i would pay that i would i would
i would [ __ ] i would vote for that to
be a ticket people would just scumbags
nobody's getting raised that's the
problem you broke down the family
financial pressures made everybody has
to go out and work nobody's raising the
kids
we praise the almighty dollar
everybody's materialistic everybody's
selfish you don't know your neighbors
there are no more fam but it's going to
come back vegas is my family
and i actually thought how i was going
to get out of sunday that's what sundays
mean to me yes that's what sundays mean
to me guys the whole thing i don't want
to break my moral fabric i was raised on
sundays after five o'clock you didn't do
dick you ate dinner with your family you
watched mutual of omaha yeah and you
watch entertainment disney world
and you went to bed at 10 and you're
prepared for [ __ ] monday necessary
that's what's necessary that's what my
sundays mean to me
yeah i could work every sunday and make
an extra 10 12 20 000 dollars a year and
that's for my family but what if me and
my wife break up right what if me and
mercy and the wife and i appreciate
sunday dinner it's necessary it's big
time you need time off and i need how
i remember now rogan don't work sunday
see if you could [ __ ] give rogue on a
sunday yeah because he understands
family you get all you know people say
to me after shows joe you want to smoke
joe you want i don't want to do dick on
saturday once saturday night's over with
listen i don't at lea
tell these dummies they ain't nothing on
my agenda but getting back i lo i don't
look at the baby's picture all day
thursday
and all day friday i refuse to look at
the baby when her when her and my wife
come into my mind i don't think about it
i know that what i'm doing is for them
right thursday friday saturday and it
gives me four days a week with them i go
swimming with my girlfriend tomorrow i
have a big day but at three o'clock i
don't give a [ __ ] unless you're paying
me i'm at the ymca working out because
they show up at five to swim that's cool
so i'll go tomorrow at four to the y and
work out for an hour and a half by the
time they get there i'll swim with her
my wife says because we're gonna go on a
date thursday night and i said well i'll
come back and cook and i go no
we have a thing that we do on thursdays
and tuesdays and that's we eat in during
the week but after swimming on tuesdays
and thursdays what's it cost us we go to
the habit make a family i get the salad
she gets the cheeseburger she gets the
baby cheeseburger
24 [ __ ] dollars and uh we get the
vanilla cone there awesome because
should we give her ice cream and then
tuesdays we take out the jersey mike's
after swimming
she gets the half of uh she likes the
philly cheese steak and white
with chips or cookies you guys didn't
know that this is what i don't want
where she gets the steak and cheese
oh that's me she gets the steak and
cheese and she's not on the carbs she
opens it up and eats the bread first and
then eats the cheese then the inside of
the white bar oh that's so can we give
her a cookie we give her a bag of chips
and we give her milk so she drinks that
and then we take it to the custard store
next door and i get her a gizmo whatever
the flavor is that's a light yogurt
light custard with the italian ice and i
mix it for mararitas yeah yeah and we
sit there right there in the in the
fourth floor like a family and we
[ __ ] do that
and
like last week lee and i had to do a
podcast at eight on thursday and at
seven i go ladies i have to take you
home now and they know they go home but
we spent that time
you know before i knocked my wife up on
tuesday nights when places show was date
night in my house yeah because i can't
do it thursday because i'm on thursdays
no date so one night a week you pick
and we would go to yoga together and
then we'd go eat somewhere that's great
sweaty we'd go eat somewhere and we'd be
home by 9 30 and then we watched i'd
smoke a joint watch my [ __ ] and watch
sons of anarchy on db
but i know that like i told onari's
podcast i know how to ruin a marriage
you want to ruin the marriage come see
me i'll tell you all the things go play
softball with you [ __ ] [ __ ] buddies
oh yeah yeah yeah go play golf with your
jerk off friends on saturday and sunday
and spend 200 [ __ ] playing chasing
the ball with your jerk-off buddies oh
you want to go to vegas because it's
your friend's birthday and you don't get
out too much you go to vegas you're six
loser [ __ ] friends
whatever right you know the things that
once you walk down the aisle it's all
over yeah because every time you do that
it's giving her an opportunity to go
where's his [ __ ] head at yeah maybe i
should suck the neighbor's dick he's
home next door doing nothing he's a
great guy he's got class he's got style
my husband's in vegas with a bunch of
jerk-offs
jumping up and down these are you know
when i see guys playing softball on
sunday
look i went four for four when you play
softball well you're playing softball
your wife's sucking somebody else's dick
so go play softball with your little
[ __ ] [ __ ] friends
[ __ ] softball you're 30 years old
what [ __ ] softball you're 30 [ __ ]
years old what softball what softball
are you talking about what dart league
are you take a dart and throw it at your
[ __ ] dick
your wife is either she's sucking or
she's going to suck somebody else's dick
she's thinking about it she's thinking
about it because you're out with your
[ __ ] idiot friends and she's got to
think of the loyalty of where the [ __ ]
you stand yeah
and once she starts going out with her
dumb friends that's how you blow a
[ __ ] marriage yeah cause then they're
getting hurt yeah you don't want to get
no [ __ ] doubts in the marriage i did
all these things now how do you keep it
together it's a sunday dinner it's those
little things last thursday her and i we
[ __ ] listen i hate going to the
movies in the daytime yeah but i had to
go that two hours saves a marriage yeah
[ __ ] your dumb friends in a barbecue and
a [ __ ] football i don't give a [ __ ]
about none of that [ __ ] i never did
when it comes to your wife you have to
give them the attention they deserve or
it's gonna go down the tubes yeah they
don't want to hear about me and lee went
with your stupid [ __ ] softball shirt
on you're a real [ __ ] man you wanna
play softball you should have played
softball and done the [ __ ] thing when
you were 14 when your father told you to
go play catch now you want to be a
[ __ ] all-star baseball oh yeah i'm on
the semi what [ __ ] what are you talking
about what the [ __ ] are you talking
about
i want to be around little tony bennett
soon this [ __ ] it's monday
[ __ ] june 8th we're dropping here
steve samara in the house pick it up a
little bit you're [ __ ] slipping
tonight you know what i'm saying you're
slipping [ __ ] you got either taffy
and a mushroom and look at him he's
falling apart on me
ready for another stuff no a cap no
crazy
take your [ __ ] jewelry fingers off
that [ __ ] thing all right the little
[ __ ] pontius pilot finger
put on the beginning of the next song
i left my heart in san francisco i want
to i love the beginning of that song
it's [ __ ] beautiful the loveliness of
paris are you [ __ ] kidding me are you
[ __ ] kidding me you [ __ ]
that's why this guy's still rocking i
bet lady gaga looks them and says drop
this knowledge that you have oh sure you
were dropping songs in 55 and that's
when this came out i left my heart in
san francisco what was the release on
that uh
i just got to play hold on one second
where's the volume here was this for
deaf people
jokes
yes
right here he just lights me up right
here every time
god
[ __ ] beautiful
[ __ ] beautiful i love all that [ __ ]
that's real [ __ ] brilliant some guy
[ __ ] lip syncing [ __ ] breathing
opening opening up his soul there's a
vulnerability to
that era of music
that people are afraid to express
anymore and that's why it's all garbage
gotta open it up you gotta open up your
soul this morning i almost had a nervous
breakdown guys i put on t for one
led zap ah okay
just put it on i was right then i
remembered how to change the glasses for
the spirits on mondays i always put
glasses out for you my mom my dad my
godmother i say prayers for everybody
dead rhaegal anthony balzan all of them
and i took a shower and when i came by
the shower i could hear the beginnings
of a stay away to heaven
and guys i had to hold myself up i was
like i had to sit at my wife's like
what's the matter i may believe i was
spraying my nose because i was just
overwhelmed the beginning of that
[ __ ] jam and i was thinking of
anthony when we buried anthony that was
the big [ __ ] song
oh my god i just was like god damn this
motherfucker's gonna send me a message
today and he did he got me an audition
wow
amazing [ __ ] yeah isn't it amazing how
connected everything is it's beautiful
the [ __ ] it got me a [ __ ] audition
that little spirit of the [ __ ] peppa
knows let me read out some goddamn
uh shout outs here my main man matthew
olivares whatever your name is
olivares yeah jason skinner
sarah hunt you dirty [ __ ] derek
daniel happy birthday on your 18th
birthday you little [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
joe kenyon holding it down in new jersey
cocaine tamales you bad [ __ ]
jonathan sirloin mcloyd steen over there
on facebook and my man robj244
sent me the best [ __ ] picture of the
day his little white kitty sent me a
picture of uh
dunkin donuts something with some shitty
donuts uh shitty dunkin donuts now
offers chips ahoy and oreo flavored iced
coffee iced coffee and he's like these
[ __ ] gentiles you gotta see this kid
i love there was a picture of the day
so where was this dunkin donuts they
opened in the valley because
they didn't open one of the valleys yes
they did uh oh i'm behind let's go hit
it let's see where it doesn't matter
because yum yum those mexicans at yum
yum [ __ ] those [ __ ] dunkin
donut people i'll wrap those little
immigrants out and [ __ ] there'll be no
more yum yum donuts it'll be a white guy
named jim making donuts hello tastes
like [ __ ] [ __ ] those mexicans they
throw everything in them donuts chili
verdes over at yum yum me and lee and
his wife went to [ __ ] yum yum where
lee
i go out of town and you're supposed to
stay on top of this but you're home
taking care of paula the first day grand
opening was donut day i was out of town
and lee you were [ __ ] [ __ ] around
you should have been up there online
paul t went the guy that was a guest on
the podcast yeah a bunch of people were
up there getting free [ __ ] i can't
win so we might have to make a run to
donut and italian sandwiches get some
sausage sandwiches
how far from the [ __ ] thing figure it
out lee god damn it now you're pissing
me off domingo says that's ventura and
white oak hold on you're supposed to get
lee i think
i just remembered that they put a dunkin
donut and leaving to say [ __ ] to me
because he's [ __ ] slipping
i've been telling you people for weeks
he's slipping and you don't believe me
not about the podcast he's slipping in
life all right so wait this is a ventura
he's really figured out that's why i
love this
it's like a mile away what is it called
domingos yeah which is just do ventura
and white oak oh [ __ ] it's right around
the corner i think
yeah the only [ __ ] good donut dunkin
donuts that's still going to eat is the
apple and spice yum yum is too [ __ ]
strong oh dude it's so close yum yum on
how what's gross no i said it's so close
it's a 0.9
we're gonna do a kiln let's go to
domingos get a sausage then take the car
up get a little coffee that black
brazilian they got the god
that is worse than meth that's what
georgie's drinks with like three [ __ ]
uh packs of [ __ ]
marlboro reds and [ __ ]
the loneliness of paris
i can't but this is the best news ever
yeah nobody [ __ ] knew it was the
grand what was national donut day two
days ago i don't even know
i didn't eat nothing
but uh no yum yum it was a [ __ ] up day
we went to me leaves oh my god that's so
funny [ __ ] up one night at the ice
house
and they're like she's in the back i'm
doing 90. they couldn't figure out what
my rush was and i hit the left on
magnolia and they're like why are you
taking it i thought you missed the turn
i didn't even [ __ ] know and i pulled
into yum yum you should all like the
both of them went
like like i was taking them to a horror
movie and it's like dark and there's
lights in there like when you walk into
yum yum donuts if you're a little high
tell me it doesn't seem like the [ __ ]
twilight zone because there's a thousand
lights
there's a cop there it's terrifying who
was we were not yeah we were we got to
start an open mic at yum yum it's on
monday nights at 10. after we get out of
here what do you think lee the church
open mike just don't even tell yum yum
donuts because you can't you don't need
a microphone you don't need no [ __ ]
money
yeah just get in the corner and pull
some tables together and say we're doing
a comedy show
i love donuts if you guys bought like a
couple dozen donuts they'd probably let
you listen they wouldn't give a
frenchman's [ __ ] even if they bought a
dozen you ever go in and buy a dozen
they always give you like 19.
those mexicans don't [ __ ] around they're
they're nice
guys if you live in the valley what is
it magnolia and colfax yeah oh they're
they're everywhere across from my food
no no no
that's the one that's a good one oh yeah
go to that oxnard one it's by the high
school go to the oxnard that oxnard is
kind of bad you do have it too yeah yeah
no no no no no no that bell that one
right there by the high school they
don't [ __ ] around and the place next to
it ain't bad either guys that little
cheesesteak place
burger place that [ __ ] place ain't
bad i always wanted to try that place me
and my wife used to walk around the
neighborhood we moved here we walked in
there and then we got the burger it
wasn't bad it was like and they have a
special like 5.99 i don't know sometimes
when i get high i like going yelp when i
search like cheeseburgers and stuff
so i just saw it on yelp one night
and what they say about it isn't a
decent yeah it's not bad but it's a high
school one they gotta be good unless the
kids get malaria and everybody pukes and
shits
some other people have to do that what's
that going on when they're high just
like looking good looking for food just
look for y'all oh yeah when you're under
there that's what you do in the
[ __ ] you should be out getting son
you [ __ ] you're like a vampire jew
there's no jews to the vampires you're
the only [ __ ] one
look at you
speaking of food you know there's a
grimaldi's down in uh
by uh the airport i heard something like
that and i had heard that rumor and i
was like is that right because i always
get grimaldi's confused with the other
one from chicago so i just thought they
were wrong
what's the one you went through with
paul with the peppers and the [ __ ]
purtilla
so i just thought that they were saying
the wrong word there's a portillo's in
orange and there's a great down in uh
like carmosa redondo
torrance somewhere down there south bay
i had never had like the italian beef
sandwich before how [ __ ] was it i
thought oh it just melts and if you get
the italian beef with the sausage in the
middle and dip that down put sausage in
the thing that's how they do it half and
half oh that's a [ __ ] heart attack
yeah dog when you put that in my for
what's the name of my fitness tracker
content
one of my favorite uncle joey quotes is
you you looked at me and you go if we're
gonna get fat we're gonna get fat off
the good stuff and i think about that
all the time i've been telling lee for
20 years you don't want to believe me he
wants to go eat [ __ ] food and then get
pissed off and i tell him it's not worth
putting in your body right i'll eat
something else and garbage right
like i stopped eating chinese i had to
stop it was an insult to my [ __ ]
moral fiber yeah it was a [ __ ] insult
every time i walked in that egg roast
they don't know how to do it no and
they're nice people oh that green apple
they're the nicest people in the world
the filet mignon the chinese style filet
mignon is to die for but i just had to
stop [ __ ] going in there that's
what's killed i've lost 23 pounds
because i stopped eating garbage anymore
yeah i had to stop i had to [ __ ] stop
eating all those bread you know it's
just that to go food is terrible it'll
[ __ ] kill you yeah and you know in
this city i think
it's not good so if it doesn't taste
good on top of it i'm like forget it oh
my god denver i went to this place
called sam's ah
did you have the chili reeno's totally
about this moment oh my god that's the
first that's the first [ __ ] i
called because it said divers drives and
divers driving some knives and it's
right across from the hotel and i went
like
i was there for three days and i ate
eight meals in three days oh i got up at
five the one morning just to catch the
breakfast before radium
you open up with a cup of green chili
because that's why i did a cup of green
chili one tortilla they're like a
thousand [ __ ] grams of carbohydrates
tortillas oh no don't tell me that yeah
i didn't know i would take three of them
and dip them in there and i went up to
my room put it in [ __ ] whatever and
i'm like what have i done i'm over the
[ __ ] carb limit so for dinner i was
going i was getting a six ounce sirloin
and i would eat half a baked potato and
the mixed vegetables
and i wouldn't eat the bun the the
[ __ ] butter on the bun delicious that
i ain't i ain't a six ounce sirloin all
[ __ ] three nights at sam's that's
good that had breakfast all three
mornings at sam's with the cup of green
chili i wouldn't eat the potatoes i only
eat one piece of wheat bread with the
two uh eggs that's beautiful it was the
bacon was [ __ ] delicious lee
what do we spend for food tell the
breakfast you ready the number four
that's what that is two eggs home fries
two pieces of toast and coffee number
four it's 4.49
you know what my breakfast was every day
except saturday it was 13 bucks it was
980 every day and that was for a cup of
green chili two eggs four strips of
[ __ ] country bacon
a pile of potatoes
great wheat bread when they [ __ ] put
the wet butter on it and it soaks into
your bread so by the time you get the
[ __ ] yolk just stays on that bread
are you [ __ ] kidding me i was going
in there for dinner and people were
still having breakfast tell lee about
the [ __ ] smothered burrito what
it looks like oh i kept dreaming about
getting the ground beef he caught me
sick i'm scared to get it
dog i can't i work hard dog i'm trying
yeah i gotta get under 300. and then we
could gamble but for right now i can't
it's tough every pound yeah you work for
every mile at 50. i work every [ __ ]
it's like football the longest yard you
work for every [ __ ] yard i'm working
for every [ __ ] yard yeah so i don't i
have to i mean there's times i had a
milkshake with lee we split a cheesecake
i gained four [ __ ] pounds in vegas
yeah i just got off the road i was
eating garbage and i had a pair of jeans
and i went son of a [ __ ] they just
didn't fit right last night i look like
sausage i get fat when i eat water when
i drink water now i gain a [ __ ] pound
so it's just it's just you got to watch
you know for me for you guys we're
trying to
do that that that [ __ ] burrito there
it's just phenomenal looking the green
chili the cup was 258 calories not too
many carbs that's so healthy for you
almost all protein and fiber and all
delicious stuff your [ __ ] sinuses the
green chili there i'm more of like out
here in california i do the red
red sauce in denver the greens is
amazing
they're different yeah
new mexico colorado
and i think tucson cooked that same then
you get to texas and it's called tex-mex
so there's three there's three or four
different styles of mexican cooking [ __ ]
like that
so good this is a great podcast today i
like i enjoyed the topics we spoke about
and
so just you being here on monday night
is always great i was trying to get you
like three weeks ago i had somebody
scheduled for this afternoon i really
liked the guy but my monday nights have
to be a comic to really i want them to
have a [ __ ] morning to go wow that
was a great podcast lee was high
thursday we'll do a thing about sistema
he's a great guy or i'm gonna have the
guy that just uh
this kid friend of mine eric medina
he used to date a friend of mine bonnie
and he opened up a
you going to jiu jitsu tomorrow night
i if i can with this thing i guess yeah
you're going forget about the eye don't
even blame the iron we'll put a patch on
you make sure you go he went to jiu
jitsu that's great i'm very proud of he
has no idea because i tried to explain
to him i go lee you hang out with me and
steve simone
you hang out you hang out with 240 50
year old guys yeah and at night he gets
the agostino once a month yeah beside
that you sit down for [ __ ] paula i go
hang out with some 25 year olds that's
true get off that [ __ ] steadmill that
treadmill that gives you that eye
infection all the [ __ ] time because
you're touching it then you go home and
don't wash your [ __ ] little juice
fingers and you give yourself the
unpunches pilot that's what that is a
punches but lee it's gotten bigger since
you've been here
so you got to go call paul and tell you
coming over to put the pepper on your
[ __ ] eye he went two weeks ago when
it first happened and what it was going
on i put the medicine in there the mess
never [ __ ] did do gods for you and
his mother-in-law said i'll put a pepper
in your eye the mexican stuff the
remedies and he wouldn't do it he was
scared of the pepper he didn't work that
[ __ ] works no
he didn't do it
he didn't do it i got mad at him i go
that's your mother-in-law she doesn't
want to do it when in doubt listen to an
uh
an older woman yeah whatever that she
loves you yeah she's not going to burn
your eyes she loves you call paula tell
you headed over there tonight you
watched by uh bring the telly you're
gonna stop and get uh yum yum donuts for
them i told her i was gonna do it
tomorrow and you're gonna get planitos
you can't do it tomorrow you gotta do it
tonight lee tomorrow you're gonna wake
up with you know you're gonna be shot
you're gonna look like rocky
yeah
something you're doing something with
your eye you're looking good you know
jiu-jitsu is good for you even if you
don't like it something differently
you gotta go mingle with kids your
[ __ ] age you're gonna be
the oldest [ __ ] 26 year old ever you
want to be the oldest 26 year old
[ __ ] guy that's why i give you the
mushrooms and [ __ ] to loosen you up if
not he'd be all wired soprano up
shooting people
calling [ __ ] what the [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying
that's why i love this [ __ ] kitten i
love them with all my art but
look at them we're going to go to boston
but the plane tickets are seven [ __ ]
50 base
[ __ ] plane tickets
they're [ __ ] america the airlines
[ __ ] america
uh
as well i don't understand no more
what do you got going on talk to me
what's the next move for
you did the great cd you know you're
doing this stuff for gabriel like i told
you you're pointing in the right
direction i know that you get frustrated
yeah you get frustrated every 90 days
you want to go home and work in your
brother's dental clinic
and make [ __ ] braces for 13 year olds
and [ __ ]
but you're in you're invested now yeah
you can't go nowhere it's only going to
get better that's what these young
comments you told me get the cd you
helped me a lot because i used to be a
prisoner of perfection i call it if it
wasn't perfect i was a because it was
fear it's a form of fear it's fear and
you go if it's not perfect i i don't
want to do anything i'm not going to jiu
jitsu until i get in shape that's what
you just do is go to jiu jitsu you get
your [ __ ] nobody's going to laugh at you
right you're going to do great it's like
anything else everybody's always
preparing
for the thing all right just go out and
live so then i put this as soon as the
cd came out now i'm looking i'm going
wait i'm
i'm making a living
i don't know how it's coming in
it's it's never and it's taught me how
to live i don't live in the future
anymore but i go you know what the phone
rings i get a gig
and it works out so that's it i've been
busy been around the world twice you
don't need to question nothing now all
you need to do is get up every monday
and keep doing what you're doing i got
this the other day and i really wanted
to talk to people about this and it
sounds kind of stupid and gay but let's
just discuss this real quick i got this
off at google
and it was 16 things that people do on a
monday successful things that people do
on monday
i've been doing 11 of them
because naturally mainly i've always got
justice
get up early
that's why i don't want to [ __ ] fly
there's no comedy club that's worth for
me to fly monday monday you have to be
ready ready to go not you know and
that's why i tell lee again lee and i
got into it about a year ago i go lee
you have to be at work monday gotta fly
back saturday yeah yeah but i don't give
a [ __ ] you gotta fly back saturday yeah
that's it get rid of it you guys bounce
back one day to bounce back you cannot
get in at 11 and do a job at eight in
the [ __ ] morning you cannot it's a
[ __ ] shitty job it's anybody it's not
just it's anybody you got to get up
early i don't give a [ __ ] what they tell
you you get back you have to take a
vacation from the [ __ ] vacation
absolutely all right exercise on a
monday
this is the one i have a healthy
breakfast you know that monday that
starts your week you know work you got
to be that eight you don't have to be
there till late there's gonna be trap
then get that arrive early whatever you
got to do make it a point monday just
monday yeah i don't give a [ __ ] what you
do tuesday you know greet the team
good morning everybody you talk to when
you wake up in the morning if you don't
say i love you in the morning first
[ __ ] thing it ain't gonna work out
for you man that's true you know i was
thinking about that book the the warrior
remember years ago there was a big thing
people were getting involved with some
uh
book the creative
unleash your creation oh the warriors
spirits
yeah i remember that the big thing about
them is they tell you when you wake up
in the morning is to write
just get up you don't have to be a comic
or [ __ ] anybody because when you get
up what's the first thing you do
go to the bathroom how bad does it smell
to pee
pretty bad okay now if you have your
first cup of coffee what happens in bowl
of cereal
take a [ __ ] okay
so if you if you everything has waste
what about your mind
what about the [ __ ] you saw the day
before that you dreamt about now it's in
your mind that you might wake up a
little [ __ ] up over so you know what
if you usually get up at 7 30 because
you got to be at work of it you're a
[ __ ] loser get up at 6 45 get that
cup of coffee that's seven you sit down
and relax and write out
what you woke up with
right every morning why do i always wake
up with a song in my head every morning
that's a song track that's the
soundtrack of my [ __ ] day
i'll show you the notebook what i write
my penmanship's off yeah my words are
off my spelling is off
this you know i go from talking about
comedy to talking about legions you're
just literally you're sitting in the
tubes you clean the tubes two pages
don't get up don't [ __ ] get up i'm
buying a notebook on my way home don't
get up just i look at that thing it's
like getting home it's like drinking and
trying to write jokes and you wake up
the next morning and look at them it's
reverse yeah it's your mind's waste in
the morning
just sit that's 15 minutes that you're
gonna be so much [ __ ] better person
your work you're gonna be you ever write
a lot and have to go on stage that night
like when you write your script you're
not writing comedy you're writing your
script yes go on stage and see what
happens to you that night you will bring
down the [ __ ] because you're still
writing it doesn't have to be counter
you do better when you don't write
comedy and get on stage but you write
something you write a chapter in your
book you write your bio whatever the
[ __ ] you write it's gonna everything you
know i remember going to karate once a
week i was 400 pounds i was snorting
blow and i saw in the gear
and i told him i looked him in the face
and i said i'm really sorry about not
going to class he goes like with my
traveling i made a bunch of excuses
if you go once a week it's going to help
you
once a week because everybody knows that
if you go once you're going to go twice
you're eventually going to go twice
better habits
when i tell you about jiu-jitsu elite
you're only going to go on tuesdays
only on tuesdays until one day you go
you know what man i'm sick and tired i'm
not figuring this out i'm gonna go to
day class today
and that's when you just no he ain't
going nowhere now look at him he's
sitting there like a dunce you're
sitting like one of jerry's kids staring
out in the [ __ ] space
thinking when they're gonna let him out
of this cage what did he give you before
the podcast
give me your [ __ ] jamonkey lucky i
love you i'd be 1911 on you
where we going for donuts tonight sure
you go for a couple [ __ ] uh
uh yum yum sorry
always all right so where you at the
next couple weeks
i'm in town i'm finally in town and
where you at this summer what club
june 30th i'm doing a podcast show down
at nerdmelt on sunset hopefully the
special guest will be roddy piper okay
uh there's a sponsor that's gonna do a
pizza party they're like let's throw a
little kid birthday party for grownups
good times so i was like you know what
it's gonna be a party i'm gonna have the
party starter taryn carter open up the
show i'll go out to like five minutes
thank everybody for being there
tuesday june 30. if you're into oh
that'll be the best if there's free
pizza and lee will definitely be there
oh my god oh it's gonna be great and
then so that's i'm really looking
forward to that and then uh i'm going to
do holy comedy through the 10th on the
11th and then depending on the plane
tickets i'll probably be at helium and
philly the week after that with steve
byrne and then toronto in august and
that's my summer i have a
100 pages of a family-friendly
feature comedy that i
god willing next three weeks i'll have
it the time to look it over and get it
good and send it out and see what
happens your eyes from your eyes
close your eyes for five minutes i want
you to think about
when we were on the road with uh what's
his name what year was that 2002 maybe
2003
how broke you and i were oh god the
shape i was in i remember you and dice
trying to get me to the gym i was about
to die i was pale yeah you know um
that's a long time ago simone
so i think that first time would have
been 2001. it was a long time ago
somehow me you bobby lee jim noy my god
that was a long time ago that was even a
little before opium anthony
he was just he wasn't honest yeah he
wasn't on opening yeah
if you close your eyes and you think
about that
this journey is that much better just
the fact that we're still [ __ ]
goombas it's the best to me that's
everything that's everything just the
fact that we're still in this [ __ ]
game whether we're broke
poor depressed we're still here yes how
many people have gotten up and left
already sure left said you know what
yeah oh it's for [ __ ] you got to be gay
to be in l.a [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
didn't do the work and now you're
blaming it on whatever you didn't do the
work i think a raging bull
you never had me down right
you never had me down
just keep on getting punched and punched
and now i gotta be honest with you i'm
stuck i believe now i already feel like
i made it because of my relate because
of my friends it's like this is it every
day is a gift i'm paying my bills
what else do i want
i'm happy i'm the happiest person i know
it's all blessed thank you for keeping
us as a family thank you for i look at
that picture and it's like it's a great
picture of us three we're [ __ ] family
you know it's the best then we got aries
for fear and we got winners easy right
as easy's moving out this summer i can't
wait for that then before you know what
ariel will be back
yeah he's moving to pasadena
it's gonna be great
he hasn't sold the house yet
no i'm um no we straightened that out so
you're gonna live there like a doctor
god bless you see you all depressed when
i remember you know what that was the
final piece
where not to get relit but i'm starting
to finally learn how to trust
and
like when you were talking about being
on the set of the longest yard and
something about you just almost didn't
feel worthy to be there i lived my life
like that for too long were blessings
that's what i meant blessings would come
into my life and i didn't feel you
judged her so i told god no yeah i said
no i deserve to be in hell and now i'm
going wait a second i don't deserve i
deserve i don't want to be in hell
anymore no more right so now i just go
all right i can't
i can't control anything really i wake
up every day i work hard and i do all i
can do but i leave the results to god
and trust it's all going to work out and
you know what it always does it always
does it always sat there on the plane
back from colorado going
if you had any idea what was in my mind
when i left town
when i was driving out from boulder to
longmont to catch whatever road i had to
catch to 70 west i don't even remember
anymore
you guys have no idea what i was
thinking i mean i just paid for gas with
an extra driver's license i had wow i
found out that if you fill up your tank
you don't have the money they'll say
yeah just give me your license and come
back i had two licenses i found them as
i was leaving i said this is a free fill
up this is 800 miles on somebody that's
how i left both giving these people a
license and leaving
a thirty dollar whatever it was that's
right the tank then i don't [ __ ] know
and just how i felt how bad i felt about
myself
how angry i was at my ex-wife and the
daughter
and through all that like through all
that junk
i still had enough belief to get in the
datsun b210
and drive to ogden utah and say i'm
never coming back you have to ogden i
like ogden i forget what run that was i
forget where even you end up it doesn't
matter you know
but that tuesday i drove to ogden utah
and the first night i had to share a
room with the comic wow
i still remember one of the comics jokes
that first night he was a good guy from
new york and he said this joke that
oh my god
i can't remember the [ __ ] closure but
he used to kill he was horrible
but he had this joke about a
you want to get a woman hot wipe your
dick in the curtain or something
that's a street joke
yeah
how do you make uh so
such a woman you dream twice crazy
and they asked them why they're gonna
hurt my dick on the curtain
that yeah [ __ ] yeah it was a street
joke used to say i thought it was
[ __ ] i remember that remember the
first time i heard that i was dying
i have two jokes that i died off the bat
one i totally jesus
a bishop and a [ __ ] uh
some jew is sitting on a park bench and
jesus is walking in central park and the
the cardinal says jesus come over i got
cancer you know heal me you're healed
and the little cardinal what what can i
do for you the priest what can i do for
you you know yeah i have foot cancer
heal me he looks at the rabbits what can
i do for you guys don't touch me on
disability that to me is one of the best
jokes i've ever heard
and the one with the [ __ ] jesus on
the mountain with the two thieves and
you know peter peter and peter gets beat
up and he runs up and they throw him
back down and then
peter pete and he runs up to nazareth
and they beat him up and they throw him
down the hill and he's just about to
punch the ticket for jesus he looks up
[ __ ] peter and this time yes my lord
and peter runs up throws this guy out of
the way punches the roman soldier gets
stabbed in the back and as he gets to
jesus because yes my lord he goes i can
see your house from here first time i
heard that [ __ ] joke i thought jesus
right that's a [ __ ] great joke we're
wrapping up with that steve simon i love
you [ __ ] i'm home this weekend but
next weekend i'm in wise guys utah and
the week after that i'm going to [ __ ]
laugh boston [ __ ] both places have
tickets available for you i want to give
a shout out to my sponsors on it you
know
i'm blue in the [ __ ] face with this
[ __ ] already today i went to jiu jitsu i
dropped two of those [ __ ] shroom
texts i was sweating profusely i went to
jiu-jitsu at a quarter of 10 and i
walked out at 11 30.
my underwear were [ __ ] i had to take
my underwear off wow my new uh my me
undies
the sweat from my back and the [ __ ]
ghee
it was
brutalized you know what man i did a
good class again today was just me and
him we rolled like three five-minute
sets so that's way beyond i've never
done and i credited the shroom attack
that's how good this product is even he
can ask me last week because your cardio
has improved yeah the 20 pounds has
helped to take it off me
but you know what i've been going to the
treadmill but every all that [ __ ] i do
because of the recovery progress that
honor gives me whether it's the new mood
the shroom tech the alpha brain this
[ __ ] will work this [ __ ] did they still
make that hemp protein you gave me yes
that stuff was delicious
delicious and i'm telling you i felt
stronger i felt like more the [ __ ]
chocolate it's not the
it's not the
it's not whey protein it's plant protein
it doesn't make you feel like right your
digestive you [ __ ] a lot more yeah
that's weird when i don't do the protein
when i don't do the protein for a few
days the whey protein it clogs me up she
gets clogged up in there but the organ
that uh the hemp of course delicious
delicious i think i might have one in
the house follow me home that would be
great i may have one in the house so do
me a favor you heard it here from the
[ __ ] horses now on it go to honda.com
right now and press in church and get 10
off your first [ __ ] order okay you're
gonna love this stuff there's a hundred
percent money-back guarantee on the
alpha brain you don't even have to
return the product what does that tell
you when somebody believes in their
flagship that much you can't [ __ ] around
with them go to honor.com right now they
also have to stay on a program which
gets mailed to your house on the first
every month you have to worry about
nothing
also who's on today
i'm too [ __ ] high oh [ __ ] hit these
things i went to the wrong [ __ ] place
that's why what is wrong with me
lost gummies or manos for the best
boomies in business you have to be a
california resident but they also have
nailed it life.com which is they make
the best baby pet on the market okay
it's 50 bucks they give you 20 off it
goes all the way down to
40 bucks it's not that what you're
paying for do you go to 40 bucks no no
it's not that big for 40 bucks it's the
service they give you i love that dave
guy you call them with something's
missing a [ __ ] thing in your pen they
will mail it to you the next day that's
what you're paying for all these other
vapor pens you buy they better break
they don't know [ __ ] nothing the one
thing with nailed it life we've
discussed it a couple times and i've had
people hit me up on my thing going joey
they're [ __ ] great the thing broke
they sent me a new piece blah blah blah
money 100 money back guarantee go to
nail the life dot com right now if
you're a vapor or a dab dude press in
what joey diaz boom and get 20 off the
[ __ ] vapor pen right now knock it
down to 40 all right who gives you that
type of [ __ ] act plus they have
t-shirts on there anything that you want
to use for dabbing go to nailed it
life.com right now
what else oh [ __ ] hit e6
the baddest electronic cigarettes out
there in the market you know why because
you get 1200 guaranteed pups just like
having three [ __ ] hookers suck your
dick for a month 1200 guaranteed [ __ ]
pups whether it's the cigar whether it's
the light cigar or whether it's just 24
milligrams 16 milligram 8 milligram or
the zero these things have 1200
guaranteed pops if you go to 7-eleven
you buy one of the [ __ ] things there
you're going to smoke it for an hour and
a half tops go to 86.com and press in
joey's church boom and get one off 20 20
off your order plus right now they've
given you five of these for 50. get the
whole quit smoking program and get the
cigar for 50 bucks pressing what in the
box you get all figured five for 15.
five for [ __ ] 50. you can't beat that
right now order that right [ __ ] now
if you're thinking of splitting and last
but not least one of my all-time
favorites iron dragon tv
the best classic martial art films you
understand me if that's what you're into
if you don't know that genre you're
slipping in fact we had a guy tonight on
twitter that said he was watching uh
some of the bruce lee stuff he couldn't
believe how good the big boss was they
don't have bruce lee stuff but what i'm
trying to say to you is they had those
classic martial art film that run run
shaw made so if you're into that [ __ ] go
to irondragontv.com and press in
boom and get two free [ __ ] films
delivered to the house you got iron
dragon tv you got hidey sigs you got los
gumi ser manos aka nailed it life and
you got honor.com steve simone who's
better than you i love you
i love you though i'm as [ __ ] up as a
can of worms that's why i love this
business
everybody um we'll be back thursday at
some [ __ ] time i don't know when we
might be here wednesday keep your
[ __ ] twitter open don't forget the
mom one in the morning join with uncle
joey 7 7 30 around there i love you
[ __ ] thank you steve simone you
bad [ __ ] you're a talent and a
half
what's the story lee why are you staring
at me down close it up i am what are you
waiting for